This video is made possible by Nord vpn start protecting your Internet
experience today with 77 percent of a three year plan by using the code
biographics Nord Vpn Dot com forward slash biographics.
North Korea is a country shrouded in mystery.
They do not allow their citizens to leave and they cannot receive information
from the outside world.
The very few people who are allowed inside or under strict supervision from the
perspective of the United States and the rest of the West.
We see Kim Jong Un as a communist leader who is threatening nuclear war and
violating human rights,
and we also see them as someone who's had a hand in a number of assassinations
of his enemies.
For some people,
that's all they need to know to form an opinion and they imagine that he is an
evil dictator or on par with that of Hitler.
But the truth about this man,
it's far more complicated.
Before we get into the details of Kim Jong,
it's important to understand a little bit of history about North Korea.
During World War Two,
Japan was occupying Korea and the country fell into a state of extreme poverty.
They became independent again in 1945,
but the country was now a rock bottom.
It was extremely difficult to raise the economy out of the depression,
especially since they were years behind the western world in terms of
manufacturing and transportation.
This desperate time made some citizens open to the ideas of communism where the
government is responsible for providing food,
shelter,
and employment to its citizens.
The USSR,
it was eager to help,
so Russia provided weapons to North Korea and it split off from the south.
In 1948,
the leader was a man called Kim.
Il Sung.
In the beginning,
things were actually going quite well.
Kim Molson kept his promises.
He improved agriculture and no one was hungry anymore.
He brought industrialism to the country which gave the citizens jobs.
They built up the capital city of Pyongyang and the country was progressing very
quickly.
For years.
North Korea was actually a head of South Korea in progress.
People loved him.
Nelson,
in fact,
they loved him so much.
They called him the supreme leader and began making up legends that he was a
guard with supernatural abilities,
but in 1950,
the Korean War began and the USSR and China teamed up with North Korea and their
attempts to take over the south.
The United States fought on the side of democracy and so they helped South Korea
win back their territory.
American soldiers are still stationed at the border to this very day,
even though the war was nearly 70 years ago in the North Korean version of
history,
America attacked first and they were just defending themselves.
This trick of years of NZ,
American propaganda runs a ban on all American made products and the feeling is
definitely mutual.
The United Nations creative trade embargoes against North Korea and refuse to
work with any communist nation.
After the collapse of the USSR in 1991 North Korea,
it ran out of money and triggered a widespread famine where citizens were,
once again,
starving people struggled to survive.
This was no longer the utopia that Kim Il Sung had envisioned into son Kim Jong.
Il was doing very little to fix anything during his reign.
If anything,
he exploited his power to the fullest extent and did things that were truly
evil,
which only made North Korea as reputation.
Even worse,
Kim Jong Il had several children with multiple mistresses,
at least three sons and two daughters are known to the public.
Kim Dragoon was his third son,
born in 1983,
so it's almost was one of the few neutral countries that were willing to work
with North Korean diplomats.
Therefore Kim Jong Il centers,
children to boarding school.
That boom was given the alias of pack on.
He got to experience a normal childhood living in an apartment with a family who
worked at the Swiss embassy.
He was given lessons on how to speak German,
but he had to enter a class of students who were two years younger than him in
order to catch up on the reading level.
At first he struggled,
but he was eventually able to make good friends with the other children.
His teachers say that he enjoyed playing game boy and his favorite sport was
basketball.
He was an average students who enjoy gym class far more than academic subjects.
He wore different in like tracksuits every single day to school at home.
He loved watching the NBA and American action movies.
His mother was one of Kim Jong Il's mistresses,
an opera singer named Koh young here.
She would fly back and forth from North Korea on a private jet in order to visit
him,
sometimes staying for several weeks at a time.
It was able to visit several countries in Europe and Japan and spent most of his
young life learning about the world outside of North Korea.
When he was 17 years old,
he was taking high school classes and preparing for graduation.
One day pack didn't come to class and everyone assumes that he was out sick,
but days turned into weeks and he never came back.
He was ordered to leave,
so suddenly that he never even got to say goodbye to his friends.
He had begun taking college classes in North Korea.
He was never allowed to tell anyone about the secrets of the outside world since
the entire nation was still living like it was frozen and some sort of time
capsule from the 19 sixties.
His older brother,
Kim Jong Nam,
was originally supposed to become the new leader of North Korea.
The second son surely is described as being very feminist and not appropriate
for a fierce leader.
Boone was third in line for successions,
so growing up he never really expected to take on that responsibility.
However,
the eldest brother,
man,
he got himself into a lot of trouble in 2001 now and was caught using fake
passports while trying to take his family to Tokyo Disneyland and they got all
over the news.
His carelessness made members of the North Korean elites lose trust in his
abilities for the next two years.
Now I'm would openly criticize the way his father was running the country in
2003.
He was exiled from North Korea and 20 year old who was told that his older
brother was gone.
He would need to become the next supreme leader.
When Kim Jong Il had his first stroke and was 25 years old,
his advisors knew that it was time to begin teaching him how to become the new
leader.
Ivr,
when his father died in 2011,
only had only had about a year of political training at this point,
but it was too late.
At 26 years old,
he became the dictator of North Korea once he was revealed to the nation as
their new supreme leader.
People are skeptical about his young age,
but they also loved him right away.
He was very friendly and mild manners,
and he reminded me a lot of people have his beloved grandfather,
Kim Il Sung,
the superstitious Korean people began to remove.
It was actually a reincarnation of his grandfather who had come back from the
dead in order to bring North Korea back to it's former glory.
There are very few living people and outside of North Korea who knew Kim Jong Un
well enough to be able to testify for his character.
Kenji Fujimoto is a chef from Japan who was hired by Kim [inaudible] to cook his
meals and they became good friends after unwritten time for studying abroad.
What'd you motor was one of the very few people who he could talk to you openly
about the outside wells.
He marveled at the fact that foreign grocery stores were always filled with food
in North Korea and were always empty or knew that there was something deeply
wrong with this country and he wanted to make it better.
He can find it in Fujimoto this,
when he became the new leader,
you plan to model North Korea's economy after China whose wealth and boomed from
that production and worldwide distribution in 2012 when he gave his first speech
is the new leader,
Kim Jong UN declared that this would be a new North Korea,
and all the struggles were behind them.
When he came into power children,
they were still dying of malnutrition.
In this first mission was to make sure that his people had enough to eat.
He spoke about his immense respect for the loyalty of his people and how they
deserved so much better.
He says,
all people should never have to tighten their belts again.
From day one.
Kim Jong UN has made an effort to be the polar opposite of his father,
Kim Jong.
Il never made a single public speech.
During the course of his reign,
he kept US citizens out of the loop and completely avoided interacting with
them.
His father and his friends in the elite class enjoyed a life of luxury.
Any help from charities from the outside world went to feeding the rich.
While baby's continued to die of starvation every single day,
[inaudible] hats undo decades of damage done by his father.
It would take time,
but he kept his word.
I'm going to set out new economic and agricultural reforms that brought more
food to the people within a year or two.
People are healthy again and was a young,
possibly naive man with big hopes and big dreams.
He truly did want to use his position of power to fix this country,
but he would soon find out so this even in the position of supreme leader,
some problems are far too complicated for a single password to fix.
Before Kim Jong Un came to power,
generals were national heroes and they were all a part of an elite class in
North Korea.
A lot of the power in government was with these military leaders.
Many people don't realize that North Koreans call their country the DPRK,
which stands the Democratic People's Republic of Korea,
but the People's Republic was clearly lacking the funding and power that it
needed.
One of Kim Jong Young's first executive decisions was to remove all of the power
from the military and give some of it back to the people and their
representatives.
His Uncle Jang song fake was a decorated general,
so this executive order stripped away much of his political power before Kim
Jong Il died.
There was some speculation that Jang Song Faq would become the new leader of the
country since we're still so young.
For the first year of his reign,
Jenkinson Faq offered his nephew some guidance in how to run the governments,
but it was clear that he was just trying to be a puppet master.
This one lasted for about a year and 2013.
Kim Jong UN ordered the execution of his uncle.
He was shot by a firing squad in the past,
whenever there was a sudden death of a member of the elite.
Everyone knew that it was an execution,
but the government would explain it away by saying it was a car accident or a
heart attack or something like that.
Kim Jong UN shock to the public by saying that yes,
he was the one who had had his uncle killed because his uncle was trying to
overthrow him and take the position of supreme leader for himself in North
Korea.
If someone commits a serious crime that are only really three options,
send them to a prison camp,
kill them or exiled them.
Considering how much power Jenksen Faq had the North Korean military killing him
with.
Really the only option Kim Jong them or say kills many of the men who were
helping his uncle plan the queue for the other military leaders running the
government,
Kim Jong Un forced them into retirements and replace them with people that he
knew he could trust.
It was later revealed in the international press that his uncle was a pedophile
and he had an arrangement with Kim Jong Il when he was still alive.
They targeted extremely young girls.
He would audition to be a part of some artistic role.
I need to become his play things.
He had these young girls bathe his naked body daily.
Basically why we're not trying to promote murder,
killing Jameson Faq with a firing squad was letting him off easy.
You can get to what inmates would have done to him in the US prison system.
However,
the western media latched onto this story saying he went on a killing spree.
This was also very shocking for North Korean citizens do.
Yeah,
because they are a culture that deeply respect their elders.
Well,
North Korea is still very sheltered from the outside world.
Kim Jong UN has actually made a lot of efforts.
You slowly incorporate modern life into the DPRK.
He has invited in groups from around the world to entertain and teach people in
things that that never seen before.
Like a group called SAF,
North Korea.
However,
these are special privileges that are reserved for the elite class.
It has also allowed North Koreans access to smartphones,
computers,
and hd televisions.
Students are also learning computer programming in university.
However,
they cannot get access to the worldwide web and there's only one TV channel and
that's used for state propaganda.
Also,
those phones can only make calls locally and all of this is still only
affordable for people in the upper class.
Kim Jong UN began sending his country's current and future leaders to schools in
Singapore,
Vietnam,
Canada runs Hong Kong in order to receive a proper education and economics and
politics.
He hopes that they will return with a better understanding on how to change the
North Korean governments and help transition their economy into a free market.
Many people get access to dvds and flash drives smuggled in from China with
South Korean TV shows and movies.
It is now common for citizens who own tvs and computers to see what the outside
world is truly like.
Even though I'm not allowed to leave.
Oh,
made an unlikely friendship with a professional basketball player.
Dennis Rodman in,
uh,
2018 interview with CNN Rodman explained that he wanted to give Kim Jong UN
present for his birthday by flying over and American basketball teams in North
Korea.
No one in the country had ever seen an NBA game before.
Despite the difficulty getting into the country.
Rodman was able to pull it off,
Kim Jong and told him,
this is the first time someone has ever kept their word to me.
He went on to explain that people usually spout false promises about trying to
make peace with this country and that makes it nearly impossible to trust any
outsiders.
For the people who have defected into South Korea.
They say that the transition comes as a shock.
There are so many more lights causes people than they are used to.
Actress he owned me.
Park says that she is always studying very hard to catch up to our peers by
learning how to read and write the Korean language and catch up to everything
there is to know about the outside world.
We will never be able to read Kim Jong Un's minds to see his long term goals.
If the truth of the outside world was brought to these people who have been
living in isolated and depressed life for so many years,
it would be a revolt and Kim Jong widow loses power.
If he wants to open North Korea up to the rest of the world,
it's not something that can be done overnight.
Remember that these people are essentially stuck in a time capsule at this
point.
Exposing them to the outside world all at once would be incredibly overwhelming
and it may lead to bloodshed.
We don't know if he is more concerned with keeping people oppressed to maintain
this power.
If he knows that the process of globalization in North Korea will take time,
what we can do is speculate
when he was alive and his father helped himself to a higher and the actresses
and singers,
Lindsay arranged for his three sons to have the ability to sleep with any woman
that they want it,
but according to Kenji Fujimoto,
the teenaged simply wasn't interested in sleeping around.
He was very protective of his younger sister and showed a lot of respect towards
women in general.
You fads to read books,
watch movies,
and play basketball over partying and going on dates which you to was so shocked
by the boys' disinterest in the heart.
And he often wonders if the boy was actually gay.
One day though and made comments that confirms to Fujimoto that he did in fact
like girls just as much as any other teenage boy.
He just wanted to fall in love.
Kim Jong Ung is married to a woman named result Jew.
She was a singer in her younger years,
but often Mary and Kim Jong.
She began pursuing a college degree in science and completed a phd.
The details about that relationship will kept secrets and then marriage was only
announced in 2012 after he became the new leader of North Korea.
However,
some say that they had already been married for years before.
Then as first lady resells who enjoys organizing events for how husbands and she
is often seen accompanying him in public.
While this seems totally normal to the outside world,
Kim Jong Un is actually the first North Korean leader who allowed his wife to be
seen in public.
He also brings along his sister arms and one of his father's former consorts
with him to events because they are part of this inner circle of advisors.
While may never know the intimate details of his marriage,
that body language shows that they are very loving with one another.
According to Dennis Rodman,
he met one of their daughters,
a little girl names Jua.
Many have speculated that he has multiple children,
but they've never shown in the public eye to protect their anonymity.
They are reportedly receiving a private education abroad just like their father
did.
Instead of relying on a mail outs take over his throne.
Kim Jong UN has been paying for the training.
It was youngest sister Kim Jong so that she can become the new supreme leader of
the country if anything should happen to him.
She is usually present during very important meetings with national leaders.
Bali is better than his father and just about every way.
Kim Jong Un is far from being the perfect leader.
North Korean citizens aren't still not allowed to come and go from the country
as they pleased.
As a communist nation.
People are not allowed to choose their own career.
They do.
You don't have freedom of speech or religion and the press is a never ending
propaganda machine.
One of the main criticisms,
he receives this for the harsh treatments of prisoners in the Gulags,
in the concentration camps,
prisoners are being used for uranium mining and their bodies have been riddled
with radiation considering that he wants to keep up with his nuclear arsenal.
Uranium mining has become a necessary evil.
Then of course,
there's the facts that Kim Jong Un has made multiple threats of nuclear war
against the United States.
This is an incredibly frightening thing to think about and it has any Americans
on average.
However,
when you interviewed South Koreans,
not many people are worried despite the fact that they live right next door,
but they believe that Kim Jong Un's nuclear threats,
so the only thing that the country has for leverage in order to prevent a more
powerful nation from invading.
Remember there are thousands of American troops at the border and with all other
major powers in the world owning nuclear weapons.
This is just a way for them to become on level with mutually assured
destruction.
Meaning that no presidents in their right mind would attack a country who has
nuclear weapons at their disposal because it would mean both countries would be
obliterated evenly.
Military training is a requirements for every citizen in North Korea.
Kim Jong never received any,
but the North Korean propaganda machine has built up this myth that he was sent
away to receive some of the best military training in the world,
so he runs military drills do keep up this illusion he was given.
The equivalent ranking is a three star general.
None of the young soldiers have ever been to war and the military leaders from
the Korean world that will gone further.
North Korea has outdated weapons that were given to them by the Soviet Union
decades ago,
and while they are dangerous and there was no way they could ever win a war if
they took on South Korea.
A man named Robert Colin is a CIA negotiated with North Korea and he sums up the
grand show of nuclear power perfectly.
One thing every North Korean leader has understood,
and Kim Jong Un does too,
is that if they lower their god,
they will be treated by the major powers as the used furniture of history.
They will simply be discarded,
walkover ignored otherwise,
why pay any attention to them so they have to make sure people care about them.
In 2018,
Kim Jong UN matched with the president of South Korea Moon Jay and the
presidents of the United States,
Donald Trump,
in order to bring their countries to a place of peace where progress can be
made,
we can only hope that there will be a solution to this incredibly complicated
situation without ever going to war.
So Kim Jong UN and North Korea scary stuff and you know what else is scary
hackers and not just off the governmental variety.
I might sort of be joking.
It chances all your data isn't really interesting to North Korea,
but hey,
every day we hear about in the news how the some sort of latest hack or data
breach of some variety,
not good.
And governmental surveillance is certainly something that goes on.
But good news,
you can protect yourself with a vpn and that's where Nord vbn comes in.
I've been sitting in a cafe with some open wifi network and I wanted to check
your internet banking world.
Don't even think about it without nor to Vpn or let's say you were a foreign
person living in an oppressive dictatorship with very restricted internet and
you wanted to watch a funny youtube video like this one very matter.
I know,
well,
Nord vpm will sort you out there too,
or maybe more likely,
you just want to watch gold local content from your own country while abroad.
Well nor vpn can also do that.
Nor vpn is also super fast,
so watching video is a breeze,
no lag whatsoever.
So if you ever used vpns and thought they were slow,
while that's certainly not the case with Nord,
you can also use it on all your devices very,
very easily.
Android,
chrome,
windows,
Linux,
and on six different devices at the same time,
all with one account.
So that makes it incredibly affordable also that are no logs kept.
Unlike some companies based in the EU or the United States,
north vpn based in Panama,
they don't keep logs at all.
It's kind of like the opposite of North Korea.
Great for your privacy.
Indeed,
they are the only vpn to get a perfect score from pc mag,
nor vpn is offering.
My view is 77 percent of three year plans.
Just go to Nord vpn.com/biographics or click the link in the description to sign
up and start protecting yourself today.
That's nor vpn.com/biographics bio g r a p,
h ics,
and use the code biographics at checkout to get started today.
So I really hope you enjoyed that video.
As always,
please do hit that thumbs up button and don't forget to subscribe and I will see
you in the next one.